[Musique]
bonjour je suis xavier mauduit voici
l'histoire de doigt d'honneur bien
souvent c'est à la guerre de cent ans
qui rattachent et le doigt d'honneur au
moment de la guerre de cent ans les
français souffrent face aux anglais les
français avec leur équipement lourd les
chevaliers sont face à des anglais
extrêmement mobile et notamment des
archers et pour tirer à l'arc il faut
avoir ces deux doigts alors bien souvent
ce qu'ils racontent et c'est que les
français qui capturent des anglais leur
coupe les doigts et pour leur faire la
nique à linverse les anglais mais de
loin leur montrent leur majeure leur
montre la gloire ab moi je laisse je
vais pouvoir tirer à l'arc et je vais
pouvoir vous dégommer et la distance est
essentiel sur le doigt d'honneur parce
que vous fait un doigt d'honneur à
quelqu'un qui a un mètre de vous et lui
va vous faire un doigt d'honneur que
vous allez lui répondre c'est assez
minable et ça ne va pas très loin le
doigt d'honneur est intéressant par la
distance les archers anglais pendant la
guerre de cent ans sont loin et montre
français qui sont eux aussi très loin
que vas-y tiens prends ça mais la
distance est très importante et c'est ça
qui explique sans doute le succès du
doigt d'honneur la première image
moderne du doigt d'honneur celle que
nous avons conservé ses 1886 un joueur
de baseball et ce n'est pas insignifiant
le succès du doigt d'honneur c'est aussi
la démocratisation c'est le score le
baseball en l'occurrence au moment où il
faut s'adresser mais de loin à quelqu'un
et le doigt d'honneur connaît un immense
succès avec le développement de la
voiture de l'automobile le doigt
d'honneur et l'histoire de la voiture
sont intimement liés manifester son
mécontentement avec un doigt d'honneur
c'est très pratique quand on est loin
ça permet d'être furtif
la posture du politique ne peut pas
s'accompagner d' insulte ce n'est pas
possible celui qui veut briguer les plus
hautes fonctions se doit de respecter
l'autre je représente celui qui va
peut-être me donner un mandat je dois le
respecter ce mets le doigt d'honneur
d'un secours rapporte à quelque chose
d'extrêmement populaire et c'est là où
le jeu est complexe parce qu'il peut
être aussi une stratégie moi je fais
partie de la société et je peux
m'énerver là où l'homme politique est
parfois détachée des réalités au point
de ne même pas connaître le prix d'une
baguette de pain on appliquait de métro
si je fais des doigts d'honneur c'est
que je m'inscris dans la réalité la
réalité du quotidien de l'énervement
regardez moi aussi je suis humain a le
doigt d'honneur est ce un truc de vieux
et bien si c'est un truc de vieux ça
veut dire qu'il va revenir à la mode
parce que tout ce qui a pu paraître
désuet doit être réinvesti et il ne peut
pas être en fait un truc de vieux temps
il est intemporel universel de
l'antiquité à nos jours le doigt
d'honneur en tout cas même si on le
comprend pas il intrigue il interpelle